Dave Bautista, you sneaky scoundrel, you.
The Guardians of the Galaxy star has got DC
fans losing their minds over a photo he posted
to his Twitter account which seems to suggest
that he may be in talks to star in a film
produced by Warner Bros. DC's parent company.
Stoking the fires of speculation even further,
Bautista provocatively captioned the image:
"It won't come to you so get after it!!
#DreamChaser"
Yeah, we'd say that's a pretty strong indication
that Bautista is actively pursuing a specific
role.
Fans, of course, took that indication and
ran with it and there's a pretty strong consensus
among them as to just what role that might
be.
Of course, Bautista is well-known for his
role as Drax the Destroyer in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe, and it's also fairly common knowledge
that he was the first choice for the role
of Peacemaker in Guardians of the Galaxy director
James Gunn's upcoming DC picture The Suicide
Squad though that role eventually went to
fellow wrestler John Cena.
Given this history, fans are convinced that
the actor is lobbying to secure a role in
writer/director Matt Reeves' upcoming The
Batman and with his build, it seems like he'd
be a pretty good fit to play Bane, the Bat-breaking
baddie who was previously portrayed in The
Dark Knight Rises by Tom Hardy.
Virtually every response to Bautista's tweet
contained the words "Bane" and "Please."
Hey a little hope never hurt nobody!
"I learned here that there can be no true
despair without hope."
Look, if anybody can picture Bautista filling
Bane's shoes, it's us.
It's not just his build; his voice, acting
style, and proven action chops would have
us totally flipping out it if he were to one
day land the role.
Unfortunately, we're approximately 99.9998
percent sure that that day isn't going to
come today, next week, or next year.
First and foremost, there's the fact that
The Batman's rogues' gallery is already pretty
well filled out.
Back in October, Zoë Kravitz nabbed the role
of Catwoman; near-simultaneously, it was announced
that Paul Dano had been cast as the Riddler.
The following month, the news broke that Colin
Farrell was in talks to play the Penguin in
the movie, and since then, it's also been
announced that John Turturro will be playing
the infamous crime boss Carmine Falcone.
That's a pretty well-rounded gallery, and
even the rumors that have flitted about like
so many bats in a cave over the last year
or so have failed to mention Bane.
It also stands to reason that assuming Warner
Bros. would like The Batman to kick off a
franchise, which is a pretty soundly reasonable
assumption — they're not going to load up
the plate with all of Bats' most iconic villains
right off the, er, bat?
I can't believe I just said that
The Joker, for instance, is conspicuously
missing from The Batman's villain lineup,
and when it comes to truly threatening, formidable
Batman villains, there are virtually none
quite so threatening or formidable as Bane,
who famously snapped Bruce Wayne's back during
the events of the iconic DC story arc Knightfall.
There's also the fact that Bautista is lined
up to be very, very busy for the foreseeable
future.
He has no fewer than three projects in various
stages of pre-production, including Marvel's
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 3, director D.J.
Caruso's crime thriller The Killer's Game,
and the animated... um, breakdancing mouse
flick Groove Tails.
Yeah, we have no idea…
Of course, it's not outside the realm of possibility
that Bautista is reaching out to Warner Bros.
in the event that Bane will appear in a sequel
to The Batman but it should be noted that
DC is being very cautious with its legacy
characters these days, having learned its
lesson from the failed universe-building attempt
of the early DCEU efforts.
Star Robert Pattinson, who should know a thing
or two about whether he's signed on for a
film or a franchise, has deflected talk of
a sequel to The Batman so it seems pretty
likely that Warner Bros. wants to gauge how
fans react to the flick before going ahead
and greenlighting more installments.
That said, we can all hope.
If Bautista does one day take on the role
of Bane, we have no doubt that he'll absolutely
kill it, most likely breaking the box office
along with the Bat.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.